So here we are in this Web page.
Let's take a look at what it looks like when we can see our click locations.
I'm going to go ahead and
open up the console by pressing Command+Option+J and start clicking around.
We can see x location with a pixel value and
y location with a pixel value of where we were clicking on the page.
For this question, I want you to use this code here to pass x and
y click values into a function called logClicks.
You'll need to write some code here that will collect the x and y click values.
logClicks is defined in helper js.
It's going to append the x and
y values to a list and Console.log what you saw before.
X location with a pixel value, and y location with a pixel value.
When you do everything right,
you should start seeing your clicks showing up in the Console.